the nomination of president Trump's pick
for the Supreme Court Brett Kavanaugh
faces turmoil after a woman publicly
accused him of sexual assault for the
first time the woman Christine Blasi
Ford told her story to the Washington
Post she alleges that Kavanaugh pinned
her to a bed at a Maryland party in the
early 1980s when they were both in high
school
Nancy Cortez is on Capitol Hill with the
latest Nancy good morning good morning
the major new development this morning
is that Ford has offered to testify
publicly about the alleged incident and
Cavanaugh says he's willing to testify
as well Senate Republicans are still
trying to figure out what to do they're
very worried about allowing a scheduled
confirmation vote in committee on
Thursday to slip but they may have no
choice Democrats are going even further
they want the FBI to investigate 51 year
old Christine Blasi Ford told The
Washington Post that Cavanaugh pinned
her to a bed on her back and groped her
over her clothes at a party when she was
15 and he 17 when she tried to scream
she said he put his hand over her mouth
he was trying to attack me and remove my
clothing she said I thought he might
inadvertently kill me Ford is a
psychologist and college professor in
California who initially sought to
remain anonymous but spoke on the record
with the posts Emma Brown afterward
leaked last week about the letter she
wrote to a couple members of Congress
people were repeating things that didn't
seem right to her and so she wanted to
tell the story herself on Friday before
Ford went public Cavanaugh said I
categorically and unequivocally deny
this allegation I did not do this back
in high school or at any time Kerry
Severino chief counsel with the
conservative judicial crisis Network
says the allegation is at odds with
other witnesses to Cavanaugh's character
someone who passed six different
background checks over a 25 year career
in public service it's not a whisper of
misconduct really it just doesn't add up
Ford showed the post therapist notes
dating back to 2012 in which she
described a rape attempt by unnamed
students from an elitist boys school who
went on to become highly respected and
high-ranking members of society in
Washington Democrats called the
allegations very credible and urged the
FBI to take proper witness statements to
railroad a vote now would be an insult
to the women of America and to the
integrity of the Supreme Court the top
Republican on the Senate Judiciary
Committee is downplaying this story as
quote an uncorroborated allegation from
more than thirty-five years ago but at
least one Republican on the committee
arizona's jeff flake says he wants to
know more before he votes the White
House says its position on Kavanagh has
not changed Nancy thank you